because like have you ever been spoiled
in like any big plot points that has
kind of ruined your enjoyment of every
any show or
i think you were amazed i'm amazed at
some shows that i didn't get spoiled
like with certain plot points and attack
on titan i am like how the [ __ ] did i
not get spoiled on this this [ __ ] was so
goddamn obvious that everyone was pretty
talking about it and i'm the only idiot
that didn't know i
obviously won't say it but there are
moments uh
in recent memory i can't remember the
last time i got spoiled i got spoiled on
the
code gas indie
which is why i'm so [ __ ] passionate
about like
my condolences which is why i'm so
[ __ ] passionate about because i was
oh i didn't even [ __ ] finish season
one when i got spoiled on that [ __ ]
how did you get spoiled what happened
because i was on some forum where they
were talking about code gears and i
didn't realize
that oh there's a second season of coke
yeah
and people were talking about yeah so
you know the last three episodes of
season two was like you know that was a
crazy ending wasn't i was like
i is it two seasons you could talk about
the kogios ending now right it's like
bruce willis at the end of
everyone knows yeah i i guess i i think
my bike was like
10 years i feel like that's everyone has
seen it right you can spoil
everyone it's it's common knowledge
right maybe we shouldn't because
otherwise we'll sound really [ __ ]
hypocritical
yeah yeah i think once enough time has
passed
and a show is iconic enough i think you
know it is totally
you know fair game to talk about because
pop culture at that point
yeah the kokios ending is universally
you know loved and
often cited is one of the best endings
in anime yeah but you should know how it
is to me though like that
that buffer is still too small right
like i can [ __ ] go ahead and spoil
like something like you know soylent
green because that's like a 60 year old
movie right but like
i feel code guess it's like there are
still kids today
you know coming in probably having no
idea what the show's about right yeah
so i don't i don't want look i've been
through the pain with especially with
code gear so i'm not gonna say
[ __ ] yeah i mean like i got spoiled on
something of a
similar capacity i say uh i got spoiled
in on like the halfway point of death
note where
something really something big happens
yeah
um and that was a manga spoiler as well
that's that's that's the worst
that's the worst that's uh yeah that's
i feel that's worse than getting spoiled
on the ending of death note
that is worse than getting i think it's
worse than any sport because that was
the ending of death
see that's you talk about that right
that's so iconic like you know what i
mean like there's some things in anime
like that is true i feel like i feel
like i need to like make a survey of
this and like depending on the survey
results is whether i can spoil it or not
right i feel like
it's like do 90 of people who know me
know
the halfway point that like [ __ ]
walter white makes meth like yeah
that's pretty like that's universally
known
it's not even close i mean i just think
that after a certain point where
something is so
well loved and so well known and so
universally like watched
by everyone in said community that it is
it is just fair to just openly discuss
it yeah
by the way please don't spoil code yes
and death note in the comments of this
episode
it's been how many years since death no
it's like what 13
yeah yeah early 2000s right 2006
right
i think yeah so it's it's been it's been
it's been a long time i'm not gonna do
it just in case but i'm i think that it
should be you know
if i'm what's your buffer what's wrong
with an anime fan i would be like the
first thing i'd be like what do you
think about
it
wow he really just said that you know
there are some things if you say you are
like a fan of x genre
that you should know like if you're like
i love bruce willis movies you should
know that he's dead in sixth sense
right everyone knows that's like the
meme this just spoiled
all the big plot twists like that is
like no no i i get it i get it that's
that's like
me how to be the [ __ ] bad no no that
i mean that's that i get it because
that's become like part of pop culture
now i would say
exactly well it's not it's not it's not
the show anymore this the
the twist is so iconic that the twist is
has become
a pile of pop culture himself rather
than watching the show
i've never seen the six sets but i know
the twist because everyone's like
because it's always used as like
anecdotally like oh it's like the ending
of the video
[ __ ] up i haven't watched it i'm not
gonna watch it now are you really not
gonna watch it now
it's still a really good movie i'm
pretty gonna watch it at some point yeah
it's not a good movie
because like i feel like right now how
would you feel if someone spoiled attack
on titan for you
because i ah i think i'd be crushed and
i'd get over it
you know what i mean would you get over
it because i was not over a win i got
spot for code yes
it depends what how bad of a spoiler
we're talking
right i'm talking like ending of code
yes levels of spoilers because there's
the ending of attack on titan
someone spoiled the ending attack on
titan for you it depends what it was
right because
if i feel like because i already feel
like it's going in a certain direction
right now and yeah
someone was like confirmed that it was
going there i'd be like kind of sucks
that you confirmed my suspicion but i'll
get over it you know what i mean
yeah i mix i've been spoiled and stuff
before and i've been like you know what
at the end of the day
the experience is still at banga and
they this ain't gonna ruin it right
right i mean
i mean look yeah like granted like you
know i finished code gas
and even after knowing that's why it
doesn't spoil it it doesn't ruin it
it didn't wrong so god damn it but i'm
thinking of like the what if scenario of
if i wasn't spoiled
because how much of a mind is [ __ ]
yeah if a scene is so
reliant on the fact that you like don't
need to know this plot point
like the emotions the voice acting the
music the animation
that all of that can't bring in like an
emotional reaction out of you
then i don't think it deserves you know
to be like guarded in the first place
but at the same time i feel like it took
something away from you it took that
fresh experience from you because
they're like there are shows like i've
re-watched code gears right [ __ ]
the ending is excellent every time out
of none but
the like by far the most unique
experience i had was that first time
that holy [ __ ] moment where i
experienced it for the first time
you can only get that once yeah i'm just
trying to be positive here yeah i'm
trying to say if she goes
if you get spoiled man don't worry at
the end of the world you're gonna be
okay the scene's still good you know it
holds up
don't worry i mean there are even some
shows where you enjoy it more the second
time you watch it but i still value
having that first
fresh experience when i don't know
what's going to happen yeah it's that
first it's that first moment that's so
strong that you look back on it years
later and be like you know is that
obligatory like
i wish i could erase my mind about x
show so i could experience it all over
again you know like that
to me that was code geass yeah
and i i think that i'm in like the
middle of like i care but i don't really
care
like it's not going to take away my if
the show's good i'm still going to enjoy
it
but i definitely feel that most people
are on the end of i don't want anything
spoiled for me don't tell me anything
yeah i want like the full-on experience
you know i mean i don't want someone
yeah i'd rather have a full-on
experience than someone just [ __ ]
paraphrasing it to me in a [ __ ] way yeah
yeah exactly